So here, let's actually build this
by simply using the two image pairs.
Now, if you notice in these two image
pairs, the object of interest has
significantly changed, but some of the
local details are, of course, the same.
Notice the same toy giraffe, and we
can basically see some of the details,
even though, of course, some of
the details are significantly different.
Also, in this case,
just to prove a point,
that the intensities are also different.
First, of course, by running through it,
we basically now want to come and
compute the color response function
as we've looked at this image.
This basically starts giving us all of
these responses, and I've just colored,
I mapped them a little bit to point out
where the higher cost-functions are,
which are all of the bright red ones,
and
that's where most of the interesting
corners have been found in this image.
And again, they are found
in both these image pairs.
Of course, now we can actually
take those bright spots, and
find points with the largest
corner response.
In essence, now that basically says,
I know what the R value is, I'm going to
threshold out and get rid of everything
else that's below a certain threshold.
That allows me to find these
regions again in both of them
that are just a higher rate,
or higher intensity, of Rs.
This image should be hard for
you to see because the points
are now very small in here.
Let's start to zoom in.
But basically, this is finding
the local maximum of each and
every point that we have looked at.
And again, at this scale,
they get to be really small.
Let's zoom in.
And if you zoom in,
you should be able to see some simple
white spots all over this image.
Don't fret if you don't see them,
because what I've done now is basically
just use contrast announcement and
now you can see these points here.
Of course,
they're still kind of hard to see.
So let's look at them overlaid.
So, in this case now I've basically
taken the same image again, pair, and
here you can see small red spots here.
Of course, some are found here.
That region is not there, so,
of course, they're not found here.
But you can see, for example,
there are some features at the nose.
There are some features
at the tips up there.
And you can see similar features, and
actually, now you can start seeing
that it found features here and
here, and also found features, for
example, here and there, even though
the image is a little darker.
So this is the output we're looking at.
We want to find features like this.
That's what we want to do
with Harris detection.